they blocked the roads they took off
with loads so why wait for an earthquake
when crooks can just take take and take
yes in the lands of syringes and poo
they stole everything in plain view
several high-end san francisco area
stores were looted this weekend roughly
25 cars pulled up us out of north
streams before about 80 people ran in
grabbed some merch and fled only a few
have been arrested the previous night a
bunch of thieves ransacked retailers in
san fran's union square including louis
vuitton burberry bloomingtales and
easton laurent
i give them credit for having great
taste they wouldn't be caught dead at a
nearby old navy
a crap of course crap like this has
become more common ever since
shoplifting charges of 950 bucks or less
were lowered to misdemeanors in 2014.
but god forbid you go into a restaurant
without wearing a mask then they call
the firing squad
but some good news san francisco's most
prolific shoplifter was finally charged
after stealing 40 grands worth of stuff
from the same target store over the
course of 120 visits
[Laughter]
they put her picture on the wall and she
stole that too
but you know what kudos to her for
always reusing her own bag
her arrest only happened after target
demanded the district attorney launch an
investigation california's da's work
less than mayor pete
and if you think that's not check out
her interview with local media after her
last shoplifting spree
tonight on the chess news network
[Music]
david brooks with the chess news network
we're hoping to run into the recently
crowned most prolific shoplifter in san
francisco here she is here she is champ
champ how did you do it how did you
steal more than 40 000 worth of merch
from the same target hey thank you thank
you you know i just took it one store at
a time and every day i stole 110
fantastic any shout outs
yeah i'd like to thank the da of san
francisco for being totally useless and
the defense that target those guys
reminding their own damn biz and
clearing a path for me and my mom for
raising a blight on society hi mom
and what's next for you oh i'm going to
disneyland for the rides no i'm going to
steal more hey is that an orchard
a true parasite and what better way to
kick off this week of thanksgiving back
to you brang
thank you
sean what worries me is that this is a
pretty effective tool i mean they got
away with it they took a lot of stuff
and it's like
i feel like it's going to be happening
again and again until we figure it out
until we regain how we do policing so
this target shopper 120 times in one
year that's twice a week yes right 40
grand with the stuff and the da doesn't
do anything but the d so the liberals
are electing these liberal da's right so
the d.a in san francisco jason bodine
his parents were part of the weather
underground truly domestic terrorists
and bill ayers a domestic terrorist
raised him and all the people in san
francisco are like listen we love your
like light on crime philosophy until
they get crime everywhere in their
community and you see
grocery stores uh and other stores leave
in the city so you can't shop anywhere
so i think now the voters there's a
recall here the voters are gonna go hell
no
we're back to law and order enough of
the you know pro-crime prosecutors i
don't know tulsi what do you do you
think that that's the kind i mean you're
seeing with walnut creek okay
nordstrom's went to that that's that
ain't that's like liberal blue state but
it's also rich so when it starts coming
to their their house
will they change their minds i think
that's what they're seeing in that
community there is people are hiring
private security in their communities in
their neighborhoods not walking down the
street anymore thinking they've got a
drive to go you know quarter mile down
the road
and and even worse than all of the the
shoplifting and and the looting is uh
that this d.a is not charging domestic
violence offenders uh at the same rate
or at the rate that they should be
charged and it's leading to people
getting hurt and in one specific case
the loss of a child's life at the hands
of his father the abuser
and uh you know the d.a gave some some
lame excuse about well i didn't think
that i could i had the power to charge
this crime because the the spouse didn't
want to and that's actually no if you're
a domestic violence abuser this is a
crime against the state and the state
has the authority and the power and must
hold these abusers accountable and this
da is failing to do it well that's far
worse than shoplifting that's for sure
yeah you know what do you think tiresome
it's your store it's your store this
happens it's my store it's my it's your
store oh we're not going to talk because
i'd be in jail for homicide
price check this [ __ ] no um seriously
um
and all
cause i had to think of something i mean
you had me follow that thanks
nice nice try but i'm still quick um
they rung the dinner bell and now we're
seeing
organized crime yeah
that mob they planned that on facebook
yeah that was they they brought it
together
they performed yeah
they put it together they planned it out
they did it they were effective it's now
capitalism they steal it they flip it
right yeah so what are they doing now
it's like a pyramid scheme they're each
going to go out and get five new members
right
and it's not going to stop and your
optimism i always love that about you
but
democrats never admit when they're wrong
they never own anything and they never
fire each other
so
this is the the new world that we're
living in and as lines are drawn you're
going to see
more vigilantes you're going to see more
people who are going enough because
you've took away our police department
you've watered down our laws and you've
emboldened the worst of our society
you know cat i noticed walking by your
office today you have a lot of
interesting new uh fragrances
so i mean i mean you must have got them
somehow on a deal of some kind i wasn't
there nobody saw me there
a lot of purses a lot of purses though
nobody saw me there
yeah it is it is kind of it is kind of
impressive that they were able to pull
this off and i don't see why they
wouldn't do it again no because it
worked so well and i'd even think of it
as a multi-level marketing thing yeah
they're going to recruit new people
that's easier than beachbody you don't
have to buy any product
what's beachbody it's like you know it's
like all the multi-level marketing
things so like you're you're a new mom
that's what they target you're a new mom
you want to be a ceo you want to be a
boss babe you don't have time for a nine
to five all that here you go exactly so
it's like you want you want you want
cheap you want expensive goods at cheap
prices be a looter i'm just saying i
think that it's going to be a big hit
with new moms yeah yeah
because you can get looters under you
yeah you become a loot boss yes and then
you don't have to go to the stores you
just point them out and the good news is
you can just go to the same store over
and over again so literally you can have
little communities and just build up
your little you know little scheme
eventually you get a whole crime wave
and then you get invited to the big
table in the private jet
and you can end up being mayor well
not that i condone any of it no you
don't you don't and on that well thanks
for giving everybody ideas
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else